- Million dollar media scopes.
How easy...
You, Claude...
And just things of that nature.
("Flow Along" by Sorbier)
It's creating, it's Snapchat.
We're dealing with Snapchat.
We have to find the restriction
that creates the upside.
The disappearing
content was the restriction,
the only people that
can compete with Facebook
right now is restrictions.
All the opportunity
in social media is
around restrictions now.
One post a day, I want to launch
a social network only for the
first year out of college.
Literally it's called 23.
You're only allowed to be
there when you're 23 years old.
That's who's gonna win.
Like the 50,
yeah, 100% restrictions.
Like in a world where a
month ago all sorts of different
scopes looked up
in the air, you know,
beggars become choosers really
quickly when they've been fed.
Ooh, that was a good one.
I feel like you
were filming Nate's head.
missed that, bro.
("Love Is U &amp; I" by FutureGoats)
CB.
- [Corey] How are ya?
- I am well.
Life is good.
Give me two seconds.
You know, I'm agnostic, right?
I want what's
best for everything.
So you should
really take me up on that.
If something's going great,
if something is not going great,
if your career
curious about something,
I've got answers.
Like I want to fix things.
- [Brian] Yeah.
- I'm not scared of it.
I feel like I'm naked.
There's no emperor's
not wearing clothes.
I know I'm naked.
- [Brian] Yeah.
- I'm running a company.
- [Brian] Alright,
that's awesome, man.
- Cool. Awesome, man.
Have a great day.
- [Brian] Yeah.
Good to spend some time.
- Yeah, really nice
and hopefully more to come.
("Romantic Call"
by Sound By Coop)
Hey brother.
- Over-empathetic
reaction to my disappointment.
- How are you?
- It's a great story.
- [Gary] What's that?
- I said a great story,
over-empathetic reaction--
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
- to my disappointment.
- [Gary] That's how we roll.
- [Man] That's awesome.
- Cool, we got a real
cool thing in a minute.
I'm going to bathroom,
I can meet you in there,
in my office.
On this episode,
storytelling superstar
Morgan Spurlock stops by.
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm super fired up
for this phenomenal guest.
It's ironic, this is really
the first time we're jamming.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] We've interacted
a little bit on Twitter.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Then we ran
into each other--
- On a plane.
- [Gary] on a plane.
I was like, "Hey!
You should come," No!
The best part is then you
walked by and then I DM'ed you.
I was like, "Hey,
you should be a guest on
"The #AskGaryVee Show."
You're like, "Sure."
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And here
we are two weeks later.
So what do you equate your
ability to break through and
what everybody aspired to
do in a world where they didn't
achieve that and you did?
Like honestly.
Especially 'cause this
is an entrepreneur format.
- I think a lot
of it is tenacity.
- [Gary] You willed it?
- I think it's not only you
willing it but you don't quit.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I think quitting is easy.
That's the other thing.
A lot of people give up.
Quitting is the
easiest thing in the world.
And, I just--
- [Gary] Wouldn't.
- I just, yeah, I grew up with
amazing parents who were like
whatever you start, you finish.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- You never, no
matter what it was.
If I didn't want to baseball,
they were like nope you're
finishing the whole season.
- [Gary] I love it.
- I was never
able to quit anything.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- And so, and I grew up with my
father who was an entrepreneur,
who started a business out of
our garage that grew into a huge
business and so I mean for me
it was always about I've got to
stay the course.
I've got to see it through.
- Thank you, my man.
- [Morgan] Great
to see you, Gary.
- Really real,
this was a lot of fun.
- [Morgan] It was awesome.
- Yeah.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
("Romantic Call"
by Sound By Coop)
- [Sid] DailyVee,
#AskGaryVee 255 exact same day.
- [Gary] Guys,
crazy fuckin' shit.
DailyVee and #AskGaryVee are
on both episode 255 right now.
So wait, both of them
are up 255, right now?
So right now if you go to
YouTube both of them are on 255.
- [Sid] Yes.
- I want to give away $255.
If you and I have a
relationship, it's just better.
Even if it's two minutes.
- [Katie] Yeah.
I really appreciate that.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Katie] I feel that there's
so many more people that,
you know, need it.
- [Gary] I get, I know.
- [Katie] You know?
- [Gary] But it's weird that
it should be the other way.
- [Katie] Yeah.
- [Man 2] Good
to meet you finally.
- [Gary] Finally.
- [Man 2] Years and years.
- [Gary] Seven,
eight years in the making.
Mike, how are you?
- Margot.
- [Gary] Margot, pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How's it going?
Don't listen to this guy though.
'Cause he's gonna trick you.
He's super slick.
Very nice.
It was nice meeting you.
("Romantic Call"
by Sound By Coop)
You've got to find
the vulnerabilities and
the truth is
there's a lot of them.
And so, it's an
interesting time.
I mean, I think, from
a strategic standpoint,
understanding the dynamics of
the private label business and
the infrastructure that
you guys have in your market,
I mean, there's
a really, you know,
when I think about as a,
I'm a businessman
before I'm a creator.
When I think about what the
impact on you professionally can
be if you can win in
this market at a global level,
the stakes are extremely high
and exciting and that doesn't
come lightly
from my perspective.
I recognize how big of an
opportunity this really is.
How are you?
- [Tyler] She won the
30 minute sit down podcast.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Tyler] We were
gonna do it today.
Obviously,
schedule got jumbled up.
- [Gary] Okay.
- We're just in town.
- [Gary] Where are you?
- Well I'm living in DC but we
are from Ohio and I'm launching
a new architectural business
after like having my kid.
- Hey! How are you, man?
- Good. How are you?
- Nathan, nice to
meet you, brother.
- And he's holding my camera.
- I love it.
No worries,
that's where it starts.
Very nice, man. Good luck.
- Big fan.
- Thank you, brother.
- You've given me a
lot of motivation in
my entrepreneurial stuff.
- Thank you, man.
Good luck today.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, enjoy.
- Do you mind
if I take a selfie?
- Yeah, sure, let's do it.
Like if you open the
Apple podcast store right now,
my GaryVee Audio Experience
is the number 28 biggest
podcast in the world.
Bigger than (censored)
and tons of NPR shows.
Correct and you are too and
I know you could be a top 100
podcast and it would speed
up FQ way quicker than if you
dominated email,
social and a website.
So now, I also know that
we're two good business people,
we've got a
million things going on.
My intuition ironically
says let me produce a show,
right, that
you're the star of and
it's a very lightweight deal.
It speeds up you being a top
personality at scale and then
you send the
economics into your thing.
Okay, love you. See ya. Bye.
Back to Ari.
Speed, hello.
Understood. Let's do it.
It's solved.
He's gonna have to say yes to...
- [Alex] Hey.
- [Gary] Hey, brother.
- [Alex] How are you?
- You have Alex Klein's email?
- Yeah.
- Good. Email Alex.
- Alex brought me in.
- Great, that's right.
I forgot about that.
So email Alex and CC me on it.
Be like, hey...
Don't ever send a fuckin'
email when you don't have to.
So what do you
think the Jets record
is gonna be realistically?
- Five wins.
- That was would be really bad.
If the Jets go 5 and 11
that's a devastating
setback for the franchise.
If we didn't beat the Chiefs in
a meaningless game we would have
Matt Ryan as our quarterback and
that's what we can't allow to
happen this time.
We would've been
three instead of six,
we would have taken Ryan and
that would've
been real fuckin' good.
- Yeah. But we didn't.
In overtime.
- Yes, I'm aware.
I remember that
game very clearly.
Against the
Chiefs for no reason.
("Romantic Call"
by Sound By Coop)
I think that we have to be
smart in like at least attacking
this in reverse engineer of what
we're trying to pull off here.
If we're doing, see what always,
what I don't want to do is make
the mistake that I can see me
walking into which is my stuff
always works because I don't
need it to be successful for 24
or 36 months after I start it.
I don't know if we're
gonna have that luxury.
Okay. Good.
Awesome, thanks guys.
- Gary, thank you so much.
- How are you?
How's your day going?
- Great.
- Good.
- Waiting around for you and
enjoying the scenery and picking
up little things here and there.
Talking with your staff.
- Very cool.
- Good stuff.
- [Gary] Good.
- Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I don't know if you
remember the situation that
brought me here.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Okay, cool.
Massive empathetic reaction,
I think that's just amazing.
Great case study,
I mean it's not little old lady
wine on Christmas but--
- (laughs) It's got those,
it's got that DNA.
- Yeah, it does a little bit and
also things happen for a reason,
right?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So who knows long term.
- Oh, you know the truth is I'm
just utterly not transactional.
- Yeah, I know.
- I think karma's practical.
You wouldn't do these kinds of
things if you would then layer
the stress of
making it worth your while.
- Yeah.
- You know to me just
it's doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
- Awesome.
Thank you.
- My pleasure.
Real pleasure, man.
- [Man 4] Nice to meet you.
- Yeah.
Real pleasure, my man.
Glad you made the trip.
You enjoyed it?
- [Man 5] Yeah.
- [Man 6] We've created
questions that you can answer
based on what already is your
bread and butter and then just
give you a little bit of context
so that you can sort of like be
talking to these younger people
or these entrepreneurs in China.
- [Gary] And this is
coming, as manifesting
as a what kind of output?
- [Sid] This is going to be
exclusive content that we
publish on all Chinese platforms.
- So look, if you
grew up in Beijing,
NYU, a community college,
I don't give a crap,
if you're in the U.S. market,
or other markets
globally and you're gonna bring
that sensibility or IP back home
and do your thing one of the
things that I highly recommend
is realizing how commoditized
the information is.
You can Google, I promise you
right now watching my thousand
videos on YouTube is gonna make
you a much better branding and
marketing expert than 98%
of the universities in the world
who are teaching
curriculum that is outdated.
What I would do,
which is unique advice,
definitely for a Chinese market
that over-indexes in it's value
of information, education is
I would shake
hands and kiss babies.
When you're in America,
if you're at Wharton,
your job is not to
figure out information that
commoditized on the internet.
Your job is to shake hands and
make as many relationships of
the future leaders of
the global marketplace.
So, this is very countercultural
for American elite students,
this is double countercultural
for you because of what your
parents have told you to do.
Look, I'm unpopular
here in the U.S.,
I might as well be
unpopular in China with parents,
you need to meet people.
It's about the people.
It's literally the relationships
that you make at these
universities that are gonna
over-index your skill set.
It's not about
siphoning out the curriculum.
You can do that
from home in Beijing.
You need to shake hands
and build relationships.
Those are the business
development opportunities of
your next 20 to 50 years.
Bye guys, thank you so
much. Thanks for hanging.
- [Woman] Thanks Gary.
- [Gary] Yeah,
take care of yourself.
Talk to you soon.
- [Woman] Bye.
- [Colin] So the cycle of
innovation is a pretty lofty
term that people
describe market cycles.
I think right off the bat, we'll
just get what does the cycle of
innovation mean to you.
- Too early, too late,
you're dead.
- [Colin] Yeah.
- Fast follower
with understanding
pattern recognition,
you make all the money.
Person slightly
behind that person, not bad.
You'll get a little fed.
Person slightly
behind that, not good.
Person behind that,
dead and loses lots of money.
("Good Yute" by Beno Maslow)
$2, here we go.
- [Man 6] Oh no.
- An original
Thundercat in package.
This goes for $100.
- [Man 6] In good quality, too.
- [Gary] In great shape.
Great shape.
What year is this?
If this is later this
could be one of the good ones.
This is, this is '87.
Fuck.
This could be
worth a lot of money.
Yeah, mine's in way
better shape than that.
Don't even disrespect.
And wait a minute,
that's for sold.
Go to completed items.
You're such a rookie.
(group laughter)
Scroll down, scroll down,
scroll down, hit right there.
Completed listings.
Not sold.
Completed because that gives
you a better indication on
sell versus not sell ratio.
Now, sort by price.
65 bucks.
Telling you, man,
she's fucking rare.
Fuck, I'm pumped.
65 bucks.
- [DRock] Out of package.
That's crazy.
- Dude, this
fuckin' shit is rare.
Guys, you're missing the boat.
Wake up at 6 A.M. Saturday.
I really wish I didn't
want to buy the Jets.
I would garage sale full time.
I got to hang this.
Alright, I'm outta here.
See ya.
("Good Yute" by Beno Maslow)
Shanghai, you're now
in Harvard, Stanford,